[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
as we have said from the very beginning
Russia Gate is a hoax and a fraud
there is now ample evidence to prove
this and what explains Trump's flip-flop
on the Iran nuclear deal
[Music]
cross knocking this and more I'm joined
by my guest Alexander Matthias in London
he's a writer on legal affairs as well
as editor-in-chief of the grand calm and
in Nicosia we cross to Alice Christopher
oh he is the director of the Durand
alright gentleman crosstalk rules and
effect that means you can jump in
anytime you want and I always appreciate
it
let's go to Nicosia first over the last
few days we've had blockbuster
revelations about things Alex that you
and I and I won't send me Karras have
talked about for years that that Michael
Flynn when he was national security
adviser the early days of the Trump
administration he was set up by the FBI
now we believe this from the very
beginning because logic using logic we
deduced this now we have evidence that
it's absolutely true that he was
entrapped and more than that explained
all right so there's without a shadow of
a doubt now that the FBI was targeting
Flynn and they were targeting him to
either get him to commit perjury or get
him to get him fired to get him to leave
so that was their goal and we have to go
back now to the mean how do we know yes
okay so first of all we have the FBI
notes from the former head of
counterintelligence bill pre step who
after a meeting with Comey and deputy
director Andrew McCabe so he was with
Comey and with McCabe his notes say what
is our goal question mark truth and
admission or to get him to lie so we can
prosecute him or get him fired there's
also some further notes that not many
people are talking about but I think
it's relevant in our discussion Peter
where he says if we get him to admit to
breaking the Logan Act give facts to the
DOJ and have them decide or if he
initially lies then proof then we
present him and there's an in others a
part that's not legible there and he
admits it document for DOJ and let them
decide how to address it this is the DOJ
of Sally Yates Rosenstein all these
Obama officials all these antitrump errs
now let's go back further to 2018
where there was an interview with NBC's
Nicole Wallace at the 92nd Street Y
conference something like that anyway
I've got the quote here so Wallace asks
coaming quote you look at this white
house now and it's hard to imagine two
FBI agents ending up in the sit room
how did that happen the Situation Room
now Comey says proud and heroic in front
of an orange yeah an orange man bad
resistance neo liberal woke audience
which collapsed by the way which
collapse of his response this is what
Comey says quote I sent them quote
something I probably wouldn't have done
or even gotten away with even gotten
away with in a more organized
investigation a more organized
administration of any references the
Bush and Obama administration Peter
that's how we got here it's an admission
by Comey we have the notes now from pre
step and then Alexander me cares maybe
I'm naive or just badly informed but
doesn't the FBI just investigate and
it's others to determine what course of
action should be taken it seems to me
that they're playing multiple roles
right here and this is a conspiracy a
conspiracy against the duly elected
president of the United States within
the government within the government of
the United States this but you know I
really want to stress here people mean
this is not what the FBI is supposed to
be doing go ahead Alex that's absolutely
right and can I just say when there was
when the Congress was looking at this is
in one of the congressional reports I
think it's from the Senate action
the FBI has very very great difficulty
explaining exactly why they wanted to
interview Flynn at all because there's
no clear crime here but Flynn is alleged
to have been committed he had some
conversations with the Russian
ambassador's the FBI has all the
transcripts of those they
know that there is nothing wrong so why
exactly are they meeting him what
exactly are they looking for and in fact
different people and you know God Comey
you've got McCain you've got Sally Yates
who's the Deputy Attorney General
they're all lost and each of them gives
slightly different reasons as to why the
FBI is into it interviewing this person
at all and of course they go through
completely the wrong procedures they
don't actually go through White House
Counsel they don't arrange the meeting
properly there isn't color discussions
with the Attorney General Flynn is told
well you don't need a lawyer present
you don't have to have any kind of
counsel there there's no there's no
warnings given to him he's not cautioned
in any shape or form and of course this
is all done as we see from the notes
which an exclusive forum has just
discussed it's clearly a case of
entrapment I say that with complete
confidence and consider also commis
words that Alex Christopher O has just
mentioned I could not have got away with
it with with in a previous
administration got away with it this is
a police official the senior police
official of the United States talking
about getting away with something is
that how a policeman talks the nation's
most senior police officer this thing is
a shocking affair it was a gross case of
entrapment and that's what it was Alex
Christopher I mean this obviously was
the kneecap being claimed the new
administration or you decapitate the
National Security Advisor I mean there's
you know general Flynn has a very long
career and he did make a lot of enemies
in the process there it is a widely
believed that he was going to reorganize
American foreign policy in many respects
not against Iran he held that position
as other
administration's but this was obviously
directed at going after Trump himself
okay and of course I mean now I'm gonna
be just a little naive here and and
sarcastic general Flynn's name is in the
steel dossier isn't it
you know the answer to that Alex a
couple of points odd Flynn Trump never
got his uh got on the right track after
they took out Flynn he went through a
bunch of NSA guys including McMaster and
of course let's not forget John Bolton
and let's not forget all the trouble
that Bolton caught us before Trump's
foreign policy so taking out Flint was
was a key move for the Neo liberals and
the neo cons at the deep state that's
point number one point number two is
Obama and let's not forget Obama because
if Comey did this I think Obama knew or
maybe even ordered in my opinion Comey
to do this because Obama told Trump to
watch out for Flint now what we're two
people exactly and kim jonghwan okay
exactly exactly and now why did Obama
say that why did he want Trump I think
for one of two reasons and maybe both
Flynn wanted to get out of Syria Flynn
actually exposed Syria to be honest he
exposed that Obama was funding Isis al
Qaeda and all these guys and the other
reason is that Flynn wanted to dismantle
the Iran deal he wasn't in favor of it
which was a which was a keystone to to
Obama's foreign policy so Obama warned
Trump about Flynn he hated Flynn so
there's a connection here there's no
doubt a connection between what Comey
did and the Obama presidency and we have
Jeff Sessions that recused himself so
basically you have in the Justice
Department he's kneecap and also in
national security
Alexandra precarious me me this was a
counterintelligence operation because of
a foreign official the Russian
ambassador at the time was involved this
is a cow
intelligence operation my understanding
is that goes for this to happen it has
to go all the way to the top all the way
to the President of the United States
it's very difficult for me that Barack
Obama can deny that he knew this was
going on absolutely can I just point out
this wasn't just a counterintelligence
operation that began with Flynn talking
to the Russian ambassador in December
2016 in fact we now know that Flynn was
the target of a counterintelligence
investigation by the FBI going back at
least as far as August 2016
then in December or January 2016 2017
that investigation is closed because
they find that there is absolutely
nothing but against Flynn at all there's
no evidence at all that he's a Russian
agent or in a Russian asset Buster's
idea for questions of his relationship
with Turkey that was but then what they
do is they decide to keep it open in
order remain open so that he can be
interviewed again about this
conversation where they have the
transcripts and they know that he's done
absolutely nothing wrong and as I said
they can't really come up with a
coherent explanation of why they are
justified isn't in meeting with him and
why do they do that well it's in black
and white it's because they want to get
in fired is that if the words are
actually there the FBI which is a police
investigation counterintelligence agency
kissed a me to get someone fired from
the US government is that what police
agencies for to get 805 okay that's the
Jim Comey FBI here vigil just come back
you are absolutely right only person II
cannot believe that the President of the
United States who was Barrack Obama
through most of this period in fact
nearly all of this period can have been
unaware of what was going on
the obvious thing is is in the air is
that there's been a grouse miss just
this year I mean a general Flynn and I
disagree with him on a number of
policies but it's not policies it's
procedures here that have been violated
he's bankrupt
he has his career has been a blemish
tremendously and he's been tarred in the
media as an foreign agent a Russian spy
I mean we I've seen people get
demonetised for quote-unquote fake news
but I mean what about all of the
mainstream media they reported fake news
okay are they going to be demonetised
and the biggest question is now and if
Trump and I think he will soon pardon
Flynn that's gonna blow up everything
the entire narrative because the Mullen
report didn't change anyone's mind
because these people are ideologically
possessed but if you exonerate Flynn
that says something about the
establishment and the media and the
Liberals had pushed all of this nonsense
on us go ahead Alex yeah fully needs to
be party there's no doubt about it
there's no doubt that they targeted
Flynn
there's no doubt Peter in my opinion
that this was a coup this was collusion
a conspiracy to remove Trump no doubt
about it this was a coup against the
United States president it was the FBI
it was the CIA it was the Obama White
House it was the DOJ it was Robert
Mueller and it was the main stream media
and while their alternative news sites
and other news organizations have been
reporting the truth about what happened
during the entire Russia github Russia
Gate hoax which is about the dumbest
story the dumbest narrative dumbest
story and we've got it right here I have
to jump in here gentlemen we have two
little heartbreak and after that hard
break we're continuing our discussion on
real news safe with our key
[Music]
welcome back to cross not where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
to remind you were discussing some real
news
[Music]
okay let's go to Alexander McCarran
London let's switch gears here one of
the strangest things that I have seen in
foreign policy directives in my lifetime
and believe me I've been in foreign
policy junkie as long as I can remember
I used to play hooky from school to
watch them or Watergate hearings okay
I'm interested in politics but now you
know I find it very interesting is that
the the liberal media the person they
they they call the biggest clown in
American politics there's Donald Trump I
would disagree with them it's Mike
Pompeo because Mike Pompeo now says
remarkably miraculously the United
States never left the Iran nuclear deal
the United States is still a signatory
to it what is going on here it seems to
be a gamma gamma now about having both
things at the same time and again this
clownish figure is being laughed at
unfortunately he's the Secretary of
State you know what I'm getting at go
ahead Alexander I know exactly what it
is I mean if this is a device this is a
procedural device a cunning plan if you
will
whereby the United States says that even
despite the fact that we've actually
pulled out of the jcpoa
that's the Iran deal of nuclear weapons
we even though we've pulled out of it we
are actually still within it so we both
out it and in it at the same time and
because we're still in it we are in a
position to say that Iran is in breach
of it and therefore that must mean that
the Security Council the UN Security
Council repose across-the-board
sanctions on Iran now I think this is
absolutely ridiculous logic ideally
anybody sees the logic of this at all
apart from Mike Pompeo and I think this
kind of juvenile diplomacy which is what
it is is going to cut a very bad
impression around the world
internationally I don't think the United
States can succeed with this thing and
all that they're doing again is they're
they're grazing question marks about the
competence and intelligence
frankly maturity of the people who are
running the US foreign policy at this
time specifically Mike Pompeo himself
you know Alex in Nicosia it's being
called diplomatic vandalism and I think
that's a very very good term for all of
this here I mean not only is it
ludicrous you can't have it both ways at
the same time there's the European
signatories to this agreement are not
going to go along with it and then and
they've been subject to so much pressure
even sanctions for not backing the u.s.
position but you're so patently obvious
that this is ridiculous on its face
they're not going to go along with it
and an issue it shows that this maximum
pressure on Iran is a failure because
all it's done is to punish the people of
Iran even during the coronavirus
sanctions would not be lifted aid could
not go there I mean this is such a
spiteful policy here and it really is a
indication of fail you're still more
failure on the part of this
administration and not just this
administration but going back decades
right now but what it does also for the
Trump administration is to discredit the
United States as a diplomatic player on
the world stage you can't have two
things at the same time that are
contradictory go ahead Alex yeah it also
shows that the u.s. wasn't you know when
they got out of the deal they weren't
thinking what's gonna happen the next
day and they definitely definitely did
not think that you would have this kovat
pandemic coming in and hitting every
country on the planet so I mean not only
did they not have a plan as to how to
deal with Iran after they pulled out
which was something that Trump was
talking about as he was campaigning for
the president that he would pull out of
the worst deal of the century as he
called it that's fine that was a
campaign promise he became president and
he executed on that promise
but he did not think about the next day
and how to deal with Iran and then the
people he put in place to deal with this
Mike Pompeo are even more clueless put
on top of this AK ovid pandemic that's
destroying every single economy a
massive health crisis all around the
world
and there's no way out of this at this
point it's in my opinion this is
checkmate the u.s. is in a box now Iran
has withstood all the sanctions they've
withstood the pandemic as well and
they're coming out of this in the lead
the US this is a failed policy the US
has to go back and rethink this but I
think they're gonna rethink this in the
scheme of after the 2020 elections if
Trump does win those elections and I
think he's going to to kind of reimagine
how to engage with Iran but at this
point in time I don't see anything
moving forward here and that would be
perfectly fine with me because a person
first and foremost disagreement is a is
a non-proliferation agreement and that
is something good and it should have
been built upon and not wrecked ok but
Alexandra cares to me the oddity of all
of this here is it on the face you know
Trump says he wants a new agreement ok
fine but I mean how how can you have an
interlocutor that wants to destroy an
agreement to your country a sign and
then say well we want to sit down and
get a new agreement I mean no sane
person is gonna say ok because well you
just tore up in a cream of the year
country adhere to from the previous
administration and now you want to sit
down now and you've added sanctions and
we're not in breach of the agreement I
mean how can I ran and I'm just talking
about rational actors here it's not
saying it ran good or us bad here
but now I mean talking about how
international relations and diplomacy
works I mean how and how can one in a
lot to leave the other one saying but
you just did this and you repeated it
over and over again and you've added
sanctions because you have withdrawn
from the agreement I mean this is
ludicrous
no one can take it seriously well what
it does is it degrades the diplomatic
efforts all all the way around go ahead
Alex well it's completely unconventional
diplomacy to put it mildly and what you
usually do what used to happen during
the Cold War which is you know the
paradigm is that you come to an
agreement it may not be perfect you may
not be happy with it but then you
go you take that agreement and then you
move forward and then you negotiate on
something else you know what you used to
talk about confidence-building measures
so you start with a very minimal thing
like Iran can't you know reprocessed
uranium and then you move on to
something else so you talk about
ballistic missiles and you come to a
further agreement after long
negotiations facts about melissad
missiles and there's always some degree
a quid pro quo here what has happened in
this case is this two things firstly I
think there is huge anger within the
United States about Iran and this goes
back a long way all the way to the
hostage crisis in 1979 all the way also
to the feeling that Iran somehow has
come out on top in Iraq anger is never a
good exactly it's never a good counselor
decisions made in anger are always
repented at leisure that's the first
thing that's that's one problem the
other is there is of course always
within the United States an enormous
amount of internal domestic demand
dynamics so Obama goes won agreements
Trump of course opposes it the
Republicans I get something which the
Democrats do there's always the sense of
the United States that no administration
is bound by whatever a previous
administration by another party has done
and that makes conducting diplomacy with
the United States incredibly difficult
the Russians say that the United States
is no longer agreement capable they use
that expression it's it's actually the
Russian government talks about this and
I'm afraid of rain in the rain Ian's
must be thinking that also and that
makes it incredibly difficult for these
two countries now which is so important
for the stability of the Middle East to
move forward together to achieve more
standings the reinforced piece there and
it's great so far it's really quite
interesting is it before the
assassination of Salim Ali there were
indications within the region to reach
out to lay around because of this
deadlock here and then the United States
that far way power gets in there
installed starts meddling again I mean
the interesting thing is is that we know
on record that Iran said that it would
leave the non-proliferation treaty and
that's exactly what the Trump
administration and Mike Pompeo want
because then that is that then they
would say they have a legitimate
response because Iran is left this
treaty but Iran won't do that because I
know what the consequences would be I
mean it's really interesting as its if
you if you watch this closely you know
it iran's my position is and you know
how it's going to react the actor that
you don't understand and you don't know
how it's going to react is the United
States because of Pompeo attempt to re
Scheffel the cards here and that is very
dangerous yeah I think that's a great
point P Turkish Iran knows how to handle
this situation they've been at the song
and dance for many many decades they
know what they're doing especially at
such a high diplomatic level Trump came
into office and I'm gonna reference back
our first segment on Flynn because Trump
came into office and he was
inexperienced I think going after around
even though it was a key campaign
promise it was keeping it wasn't the
most important you know you had build
the wall yet immigration you had other
things I were taking priority Trump came
in and I think dealing with Iran was a
mistake he should have left it once
again for the second term because he bit
off more than he can chew he had people
in place that word neo cons and that
were ideologically driven let's not
forget flame God McMasters in McMasters
God Bolton in even worse you're going
for from bad to worse McMasters to
Bolton then you have Pompeo coupled with
Bolton and these two guys are running
the show in North Korea they're running
the show in Iran and they're advising
Trump poorly meanwhile Trump has this
whole Russia Gate Ukraine gate
impeachment everyone is going after him
he should not have touched Iran until
the second term this was a
steak and now he's boxed in and he's
boxed in with compay Oh in the lead you
know needs to go the second term because
company situation better
I mean Alan in London I think one of the
things that I've noticed that I've never
really understood is that Trump just
seems determined to undo everything that
Obama did yes I'm doing his legacy and
you know as people know this program and
known me over the years I mean I do
compliment the Obama administration for
this nuclear deal with Iran because it
lowered tensions in the region and I
give credit where credit's due but it
seems to me that the Trump is just
single-minded because it's personal for
him that he must undo Obama's legacy
last 20 seconds go to you I think there
is a visceral issue the two men Obama
and Trump dislike each other intensely
and obviously their influence is what
Trump does I think also though he was
led along the way into speaking this
fight with Iran I do think this is
entirely driven by visceral
considerations he had people there are
many people in the United States who
don't like Iran it's been always been a
cadre problem surrounding himself with
the wrong people that's all the time we
have I want to thank my guests in in
Nicosia and in London I think our
viewers for watching us here at RT see
you next time and remember across that
rules
[Music]